olá boa noite
o confronto o conflito de gerações não é
algo novo
muito pelo contrário desde que a gente
sabe o que a família existe o conflito
entre gerações
só que eu vou falar sobre o conflito
entre gerações no mercado de trabalho ou
melhor no ambiente de trabalho e também
a questão da dos nativos digitais que
estão chegando agora para trabalhar as
organizações a partir nos próximos anos
bom é importante entender quais são
essas gerações nós temos algumas
gerações já trabalhando juntas nesse
mercado de trabalho nós temos eu vou
tentar explicar quais são as gerações
para poder passar os nativos digitais
nós temos os baby boomers que são
aqueles nascidos no pós que é depois da
segunda guerra mundial ou seja aqueles
que nasceram mais ou menos
enfim 1945 até mais ou menos 1960
esse pessoal já está se aposentando
vários deles já se aposentaram até
porque quando a gente fala no brasil as
leis de aposentadoria permitiam isso
hoje em dia segundo ele foi se o work na
150 melhores empresas para trabalhar no
brasil eles o corpo em 12% da população
ativa no mercado então a população que
já está aí saindo a gente tem a geração
x que são mais ou menos eu tô falando
mais ou menos porque depende muito do
recorte os autores divergem sobre isso é
uma literatura norte-americana que a
gente tenta adaptar em outros países
a geração x são mais ou menos os filhos
dos baby boomers que hoje representam
também é boa parte do mercado de
trabalho e nós temos atualmente geração
y é a maioria nas empresas de geração y
segundo esse mesmo estudo representa já
62% ou seja são aqueles que treinam em
até 34 anos de idade e mais
impressionante aqueles que estão com até
25 anos já representa 25% do mercado de
trabalho é uma população bem grande que
vem crescendo e o que a gente já vê a
gente enxerga diferenças no no ambiente
de trabalho por causa da geração y ea
gente ainda vai receber os nativos de
quais ativos digitais são também chamada
geração c
essa geração z segundo a literatura são
aqueles nascidos a partir dos anos 2000
e pra mim pessoalmente eu acho que são
aqueles nascidos a partir de 2010
são aqueles que realmente na
sim e convivem diretamente com os
dispositivos móveis têm a tecnologia nas
suas mãos
é aquele que quando pega uma revista
fala que é um tablet que bravo
então a gente tem essa noção diferente
do que é a tecnologia já incorporada eu
vou falar um pouco mais sobre isso daqui
a pouco a gente tem um contexto aí uma
população que vive mais segundo o ibge é
em 2015 a população tem mais que os
brasileiros uma expectativa de vida de
75 anos porque é bastante a gente
comparar com em 1900 ou seja 11 décadas
atrás era de 33 anos era de 33 anos e
isso vem aumentando com a expectativa de
ainda e um número maior
a gente tem cada vez mais mais pessoas
de diferentes gerações no mesmo ambiente
de trabalho
com isso é bem claro a gente tem como
fazer os baby boomers e a gente tem os
mais jovens que apesar de serem maioria
não mando nas empresas estão ocupando
agora os princípios primeiros níveis de
gestão mas quem realmente assumia a
direção e quem realmente está ali é
colocando o modelo de gestão nas
organizações ainda são os mais velhos
principalmente os baby boomers e à
geração x
a população que vive mais entende que é
um pouco diferente é principalmente o
pessoal do pós guerra como a gente vê na
história e esse é o norte que acontecia
era né
tudo pode ficar instável eu vou
trabalhar muito e vou acumular bastante
para que eu tenho uma vida tranquila
depois
e também ninguém sabe o que vai
acontecer depois não era um pessoal que
trabalhava muito se dedicava demais e
tinha essa noção de de que precisava
trabalhar
é pra uma empresa só de preferência e
eles com isso faria a vida deles os
jovens enxergam que vão ter que
trabalhar por muito mais tempo e nesse
tempo então que seja agradável que seja
interessante a gente vê um ambiente de
trabalho hoje em dia principalmente dos
jovens empreendedores que criam esses
ambientes que são mais livres que são
mais abertos em baias sem divisões
muitos muito horizontais a gente não vê
diferença exibe gestão com ambientes que
a gente tem lazer em que a gente tenta
promover a
criatividade e as pessoas não querem
divertir querem se divertir ou seja
passa a vida né curtindo a vida e
trabalhando não mais trabalhar para
depois aproveitar a vida a gente vê tudo
isso de uma forma muito mais junto a
gente tem o fenômeno da tecnologia essa
questão da tecnologia a gente tem as
redes sociais os jovens são aqueles que
conseguem lidar muito bem com as redes
sociais com as tecnologias os baby
boomers foram aqueles que receberam as
tecnologias nas organizações
vários deles resistiram às tecnologias
até porque podiam resistir às
tecnologias hoje em dia a gente não
consegue mais a geração x foi aquela que
o principal vítima da tecnologia até
porque a partir da década de 80
a gente vê um grande processo de
automação então o pessoal que foi perder
o emprego por causa disso da automação e
da tecnologia teve que se virar com isso
e hoje em dia precisam lidar com isso já
que qualquer empresa é dependente de
tecnologia e é isso que vai promover
vantagem competitiva geração y é aquela
que nasceu junto com a tecnologia e
conhecer e adaptar não há grande
diferença com os nativos digitais é que
eles já nasceram com a tecnologia nas
mãos
então a gente vê hoje as crianças
pequenas crianças por aí elas me dão
muito bem de uma forma muito natural ea
geração y também trabalha bem com a
tecnologia só que ela não é nativa como
a gente tem as crianças que nasceram a
partir de 2010 e quando a tecnologia se
intensificou e eu gosto de peten time
chegará às redes sociais relacionadas
com a geração y yo até os mais jovens e
entre 12 delas que retratam muito bem
essa juventude é justamente sachetti eo
twitter são mais superficiais em 144 em
140 caracteres que passa uma ideia ou
então em alguns poucos segundos também
se tenta passar uma mensagem para o seu
público é a tecnologia neowin que
permite o que permite alta produtividade
hoje em dia nas organizações
e quanto melhor as organizações
conseguirem lidar com isso mais
competitivas elas se tornaram as redes
sociais também têm permitido
os negócios para as organizações junto
com a tecnologia nós temos o fenômeno da
globalização que tem acontecido também
há vários anos nas últimas décadas
hoje em dia o mercado de trabalho é um
só então nós temos por exemplo o
linkedin é uma rede social profissional
que hoje contempla no meio do ano ele
divulgar esse número de mais de 400
milhões de usuários
isso representaria o quarto maior país
do mundo de profissionais que estão lá
cadastrados com seu perfil profissional
e as organizações estão ali prontas para
recrutarem para contratarem essas
pessoas hoje em dia não existe mais
barreiras existido o tradutor então
qualquer pessoa no mundo que esteja
cadastrada do linkedin é um potencial
profissional para trabalhar na
organização e por isso também a gente vê
o fenômeno dos nichos de especialidades
por exemplo se um país de língua inglesa
que quiser contratar um serviço de
atendimento por telefone com certeza vai
encontrar o melhor custo-benefício na
índia assim como se quiser fazer um
aplicativo melhor custo benefício também
da índia
a gente vê muito desse fenômeno
acontecendo e ao mercado está muito
aberto hoje em dia não existem mais
fronteiras geográficas existem vários
aviões com preços muito acessíveis
não existe mais fronteira de horário as
equipes virtuais por aí trabalham a
todas as horas todos os momentos
inclusive por causa disso qualquer fato
e seja relevante politicamente
socialmente economicamente vai
influenciar todo o mercado de uma vez
foi muito rápido e as equipes virtuais
têm sido cada vez mais comuns os jovens
só aquele que melhor se adapta a esse
tipo de modelo as pessoas trabalham
virtualmente e quando a gente fala ainda
dos nativos digitais eles vão pensar de
uma forma muito mais natural não existe
real e virtual é tudo a mesma coisa
a gente também tem a mudança de valores
os valores têm mudado muito quando a
gente fala das gerações mais velhas eles
pensavam em acumular capital para com
isso o buscar a felicidade né pra com
isso curtir a vida e isso a gente vê as
mudanças por exemplo os jovens hoje em
dia se casam mais tarde os jovens
primeiros filhos buscam ter filhos mais
tarde também
e o principal é que eles buscam acúmulo
de satisfações de experiência seria
interessante e é por isso que a gente vê
também o pessoal mudando muito rápido de
empresa de emprego
a gente tinha um modelo antes que o
ideal era trabalhar em uma ou duas
empresas durante a vida e hoje em dia as
pessoas trabalham em várias empresas ou
até em múltiplas empresas ao mesmo tempo
já que o importante é de desafiar e
querer algo que seja importante quando a
gente vê as pesquisas de ambiente de
trabalho os principais números dizem que
os jovens buscam aprendizado e
crescimento eles querem desafios e
enquanto aquele trabalho foi
interessante
ele estará lá se ele não for mais ele
sai
ele não vê ele eles só vêem interesse
quando estiver aprendendo ou então se
tiver gerando algum valor interessante
para aqueles jovens em relação aos
valores também a gente tivesse a questão
do comprometimento é muito comum as
pessoas mais velhas falarem os jovens
não querem nada com nada não estão
comprometidos
este tipo de fala né então tem gente que
nossa né como é que vai ser esse futuro
com o pessoal mais jovem na verdade eu
vejo contrário é esses jovens são
aqueles que não pensam da mesma forma
feição de uma forma muito mais em rede
com a gente fala as pessoas mais velhas
a gente tem um modelo educacional em que
tudo era linear
a gente hoje ver os jovens vêem hoje
tudo em rede e ícones em coisas que se
conectam o a noção de hiperlink que a
gente tem hoje na internet traz a noção
de que ele tem muito mais forte nos
jovens e que são muito mais dinâmico tem
uma visão do todo que é diferente de
pessoal é mais das outras gerações que
tem a questão do aprofundamento
determinado assunto então existe o que é
melhor ou pior existe o que é diferente
e com isso eles vão é essa noção de
enxergar o todo dentro das organizações
o que falta hoje em dia também os jovens
buscam ambiente de trabalho que sejam
informais e por isso as empresas
precisam se adaptar com isso disse
entender que as organizações precisam de
um ambiente mais flexíveis horário
flexíveis políticas que se adaptem
melhor essa nova característica quando
eu pergunto para os meus alunos o que
eles buscam para o futuro dele é
profissionalmente e eles não respondem
se eles querem trabalhar em um setor ou
então se eles querem ter determinada
função eles costumam responder o
seguinte eu quero um lugar em que eu vou
ter minhas férias garantidas eu quero um
lugar em que eu tenha trabalho flexível
é o horário flexível eu quero um lugar
em que eu possa trabalhar de casa
as pessoas pensam mais nesse modo de
trabalho de como vai ser do que
exatamente o que é que ele vai fazer ele
é o jovem aquele que busca algo que vai
trazer satisfação como já falei e uma
outra questão também de mudança é que a
gente tem 50 anos atrás
é como é que uma pessoa poderia começar
um novo negócio só se estivesse muito
capital inicial se ela não pensa em
capital ela não começa num tipo de
negócio hoje em dia uma pessoa que não
tem nenhum dinheiro ela pode começar um
negócio desde que a idéia dela seja boa
o suficiente pra conseguir dinheiro a
inocrowd onde não são as máquinas
virtuais em que você propõe uma idéia e
com essa ideia o pessoal contribui com o
dinheiro e um novo negócio que inicia é
muito diferente hoje
antes a gente possibilitar esses novos
negócios somente a um pequeno grupo de
pessoas que tivessem dinheiro e hoje em
dia a gente possibilita ir para qualquer
pessoa que tenha novas idéias inclusive
já fizeram pesquisas com jovens
empreendedores quando jovens
empreendedores são perguntados que tipo
de tipo de negócio você quer
quando eles vão falar do público no
mercado ele sempre pensou no mercado
global ninguém fez mais um mercado local
pensa sempre no mercado global e quando
a gente vê esses novos negócios estão
crescendo rapidamente são justamente
eles que se replicam de uma forma muito
rápida com o mercado tudo são os nativos
digitais são esses que nascem com as
tecnologias nas mãos vão enxergar o
trabalho de uma forma muito diferente a
gente ainda não sabe como mais
importante é que as empresas se preparem
para isso
quando a gente fala de tecnologia ela só
tem se aproximado
quando a gente for por exemplo pensar
nos nossos avós nossos pais
como é que eles seriam determinadas
informações sobre o mundo existe o
cinema então cinema é ter uma tela tem a
pessoa que o público
de repente a gente tinha televisão a
televisão é algo que está dentro da sala
de casa e que ainda coletivo então é ter
uma distância que se aproxima
depois a gente tem o computador
computador também aproxima ainda mais
hoje em dia a gente tem os notebooks
tablets se aproximar ainda mais de cada
um se tornou individual e hoje em dia a
gente tem os óculos
eles têm o smart watch que é aquilo que
ainda faz com que a gente tenha a
tecnologia incorporada
então os ativos digitais os que já estão
com a tecnologia incorporada desde que
nasceram
essa grande diferença e vou trabalhar
muito mais com a questão da criatividade
vão ser muito mais cobrados em relação à
criatividade só aqueles que vão pensar
sobre o dinheiro de uma forma diferente
como falei esse investimento não são
mais necessários quando a gente ia um
negócio são múltiplos na questão das
especialidades das habilidades das
competências e como falei as
organizações que bom que terão mais
sucesso a partir de agora são aquelas
que esses ativos digitais estão
crescendo atualmente vão chegar no
mercado de trabalho nos próximos anos e
aquelas que conseguirem e adapta melhor
a esse novo público serão aquelas que
conseguiram pôr mais sucesso é isso
obrigada
[Aplausos]